[Musique]
il y a deux cents ans mais c'est le
poète réunionnais leconte de lisle le
département a décidé de célébrer ce
bicentenaire tout au long de cette année
[Musique]
amer ce mardi à l'école narassiguin de
bras panon en présence de la vice
présidente déléguée à la culture du
maire de bras-panon de la délégation
culturelle des départements du
représentant de l'éducation nationale et
des artistes qu'a lieu la remise de
livres et de poésie le conte de l'île
aux enfants
c'est un besoin bras panon c'est un
besoin à l'école la racj a donc leconte
de lisle dans bras panon dans hara cia
c'est le plus beau projet de vie que
chaque enfant peut partager alors un
réunionnais à l'académie française
auraient à réunionnais qui signe un
nouveau courant de poésie c'est
extraordinaire connaître une oeuvre
c'est la connaître de mieux en mieux
c'est apprendre à limoux c'est pourquoi
le département initie accompagne des
projets très différents
nous fêtons le bicentenaire de leconte
de lisle et tout naturellement la
culture se déplace eh bien dans l'est à
la rencontre de nos jeunes puisque nous
faisons un travail avec l'ensemble des
jeunes
des 24 villes de la réunion et il faut
savoir qu'à l'heure d'aujourd'hui il ya
600 jeunes qui sont inscrits et qui
travaille sur les poèmes de leconte de
lisle
le programme de l'année de leconte de
lisle sont à retrouver sur le site
département 9 7 4 points fr
[Musique]